Today, I will backtest the full month of
March and I will compare it with my
account stats right here.
I received hundreds of comments asking
me to do that. That's why I will do
day-by-day to remove everything that
hasn't been clear for you. So, let's get
right into charts. I will leave my
positions exactly like I took them
because I don't want to waste time
looking for FVG's on the chart and I
don't want to make this video super
long. And if you are new here, make sure
to subscribe and put notification bells
on, like, and leave all your comments
down below. I make sure to answer every
single one of them. Also, don't forget
to follow me on Instagram. You will find
the link below in the description. Now,
let's get to day number one. Let's speed
things up first.
I'm just now waiting for New York
session to open.
Market hasn't opened yet simply because
at the 2nd of March we had the
wintertime. We wait for the 9:30 candle.
And also, before I forget, just make
sure that you always have here the New
York time zone to not be tricked by this
summer and wintertime. This is the
market open at 9:30. My bias was a
bearish from the start of the day. Now,
we can see a bullish candle. We wait for
a bullish fair value gap to form and for
the price to inverse it and trade the
continuation.
But the opposite happened here. I took
an aggressive trade just because we
flipped this pre-market fair value gap.
I entered here, put my stop loss at
candle, so it's protected by this fair
value gap, by the inversion candle, and
by the previous candle. So, we have
three layers of protection. And since I
don't have a previous liquidity right
here, I targeted two hours. Let's play
the price out.
TP. This day was the 2nd of March. As
you can see here, I made a little bit
under two hours. Now, let's go to the
next day.
Here is the 9:30. We have a premarket
FVG here that hasn't been mitigated,
then we flipped it to the downside. The
entry, honestly, should be here, but I
remembered when I entered, price, I
think, moved too fast to the upside, so
my entry was here, right at this candle.
My stop loss was over EMA and over the
inversion candle and over, obviously,
the FVG. So, three layers of
protections, also. And I targeted this
previous liquidity. The RR here was
three.
TP. This was the 3rd of March. As you
can see here, 6K. Now, to the next day.
And I forgot to tell you that the bias
here was also bearish because we are
simply under DMAs and they are heading
down. And also, if you have no idea
about this strategy, I will make sure to
leave the full breakdown down below in
the description.
Waiting for the 9:30 candle.
4 March, the summertime started from 8
March. This is the opening candle. As
you can see here, we are obviously
bullish because one, the price is over
the EMA and they are pointing up. So, we
will be looking for bearish FVG to be
inverse to trade the continuation.
Still nothing yet.
And we have one right here.
As you can see here, we have a bearish
FVG. We just wait for the price to break
it to the upside.
Here it is. I entered, placed my stop
loss both below the inversion candle,
the FVG, and at the previous candle.
Let's play the price.
TP. This day was 4 March.
4.2K.
That's a little bit more than two hours
for my account. Also, leave a comment
down below telling me what do you want
to see on my next videos.
Waiting for the 9:30 candle, obviously.
Here it is. As you can see, price is
over all the three EMAs. We are
obviously bullish. We had a fair value
gap here from pre-market. That's why I
decided to enter right here. Put my stop
loss under the FVG and these two EMAs.
And since this liquidity is less than 2
hours, I went for 2 hours. Let's play
the price out.
Straight to stop loss. This day was the
5th of March. I lost a little bit under
2K. This is a statistical stop loss. I
don't have any problem taking it. I
simply close my charts and wait for the
next day.
Waiting for 9:30.
Here it is. This day is obviously
bearish. The EMAs are pointing down. The
price is under them. We will be looking
for a bullish FVG to be flipped to the
downside to trade continuation,
obviously.
Here is our entry. So, I decided to
enter here. Put my stop loss over FVG
inversion candle, also swing high EMA
because it made sense
and targeted 2 hours. Let's play the
price.
Straight to stop loss, again, for the
second time. As I said before, no
problem taking a stop loss. And if you
need help mastering this strategy,
mastering your stop loss placements,
which FVG to take, how to place your
entry, your TP, which liquidity, every
technical detail of the strategy, and
also help with your psychology, making
sure that someone who trade this
strategy every single day is on your
shoulder watching every trade that you
take. Apply to my one-on-one mentorship
down below to see if you are the right
fit. Now, to the next day.
Today is 9 of March. The summer time is
here, so we will spot the New York
session once. Yeah.
Right here was the opening. Let me redo
this bar.
This day we are obviously bearish. The
EMAs are pointing down.
Price is under all of them when market
open. Let's play the price.
We will be looking for a bullish FVG to
be flipped.
Then nothing.
We have here a bullish FVG.
Now, personally, my bias flipped. Now,
I'm looking for a bearish FVG and for
the price to be inversed it to trade the
continuation to the upside because we
are now over the 1-hour EMA and I will
be looking only for longs.
We have here an FVG. If price flipped
this, I will enter.
Now, I have my entry. Price flipped this
FVG. Stop loss is under the inversion
candle, under the previous candle, under
the 1-hour EMA, and under I think the
FVG or I already said that. I don't
know. I will be going for two. Let's
play the price.
TP.
This day was the 9 of March. Yeah, a
little bit under 4K. Now, let's go to
the next day.
And I think we are already 6 minutes in
this video, although I left my uh yeah,
old positions
like this to not waste time drawing a
VGs every single time.
Here we have market open. We are
obviously bullish. Price is over the
EMAs.
We'll be looking for bearish FVG to be
flipped.
Nothing yet.
We have one right here. I believe after
this candle. Yes, we have a bearish FVG.
We wait for the price to break it to the
upside.
Here is my entry stop loss under FVG EMA
inversion candle previous candle and
targeting two hours.
I think I was targeting this liquidities
under two hours. I targeted two hours.
Let me see.
TP this day was 10 of March. I made a
little bit over 4K. To the next day.
Here is the 9:30 candle.
No, this is the 8:30. I think we had
news that day.
Here it is. This is the 9:30 candle.
Bias is obviously bullish. Price is over
all the EMAs and they are pointing up.
I'm looking for a bearish FVG to be
flipped.
Then nothing.
And for people who are
going to ask why I didn't take this
because obviously FVG is way above. If I
simplify this strategy as simple as
possible, we trade pullbacks. That's why
we don't take FVG's that are way higher.
We We here a bearish FVG.
This is my entry. Stop loss below all
these things. I don't need to keep
saying the same things. Target is 2
hours.
And a stop loss. This was from the 11th
of March.
And I lost a little bit under 2K.
To the next day.
Some days you simply can't make money.
You should accept this.
Your open is here at 9:30.
We are below the EMAs. We are bearish
for this day. We have a bullish FVG
right here.
Entry is here after this candle.
Stop loss right at the previous candle.
Let's play the price.
Let me see.
And yeah.
Target is 2 hours.
Don't know why this is lagging.
TP.
This was from the 12th of March. A
little bit over 4K. To the next day.
I don't know, like I said, why this
TradingView is lagging. Here we have the
9:30 candle. We are obviously bearish.
Let's look for a bullish fair value gap.
We flipped our bias. I will now be
looking for buys.
But don't forget we still have this
bullish FVG right here.
Then we flipped this FVG and we came
back under the EMA. That's why the bias
is again flipped. We are again bearish.
I'm targeting this liquidity right here.
Let's play the price.
Here the RR was 2.12 from the 13th of
March. And here 4.5K.
To the next day.
Today was Monday. This is a pre-market
FVG. This is a very low probability
trade, but I took it. You can see here a
bearish fair value gap. You can see the
price over all the EMAs. That means we
are bullish. The stop loss is under the
FVG. This is an extremely aggressive
trade. Let's play the price.
And TP, I just got lucky, I believe.
This was from the 16th of March. 4K to
the next day, obviously. And also,
please stop asking me if this works on
gold, if this works on Bitcoin, if this
works on Ethereum, if this works on Euro
USD. You should backtest it by your own.
So, we have New York open right here at
9:30.
I don't like how the EMAs are right
here, extremely overlapping.
And too close to each other, but the
price is way above the EMAs. That
indicates strong bullish momentum.
We are bullish, obviously. We have here
a bearish fair value gap that was
created after market open. We flipped it
with this candle. Stop loss right here.
Target it 2 hours. Let's play the price.
And a stop loss.
This day was the 17th of March. A little
bit over 2K to the next day.
This was a no trade day, to be honest.
Maybe I was too aggressive.
The EMAs are telling everything from the
beginning.
Here. Here we have a huge sell-off. This
is the first candle of the New York
session.
We are below the EMAs, although the EMAs
are pointing up, but you should know
always that the EMAs take time.
And it's a very laggy indicator. Since
the price is under them, I decided to be
bearish, especially under the 1-hour and
how the price keep rejecting it. We have
a bullish pre-market FVG right here. We
flipped it, put my stop loss here over
FVG and over these weeks. Targeted 2R.
Let's play the price.
TP.
That was from the 18th of March.
4.6k.
You see how the EMAs are acting like a
dynamic support and resistance. So, we
have here a break and retest.
Here the bias is obvious. We have all
EMAs pointing down. Price is under them.
I'm looking for shorts.
We need a bullish fair value gap.
We have one right here, entered right
here. Stop loss over the inversion
candle, FVG. Targeted 2R.
And a stop loss hit. This was from the
19th. A little bit less than 2k for a
loss.
To the next day.
And as I said earlier,
there are some days when you can't do
anything to avoid losses. Anything.
No matter how much experience do you
have,
you can't avoid them. 9:30 candle right
here.
We are obviously bearish again.
We have this pre-market FVG.
Price broke it. Put my stop loss in a
conservative way today because
yesterday, yeah, you see what happened.
Uh stop loss right here and target it
two hours.
And TP, this was from the 20th of March.
A little bit over 4K.
I think I used more contracts
on this day.
And these trades were three months ago.
So, bear with me if I don't remember
something from them. Yeah, this day was
a no trade day. This was a Trump tweet.
This was an unbelievable huge candle. I
didn't trade that day. I think it's the
23rd. Yeah, I remember that.
The EMAs don't look that good to be
honest. I think I made a mistake this
day going in. So, price is under all the
EMAs. We have this FVG here from
pre-market. I entered right here, my
stop loss here and target it two hours.
I think, yeah, it was a stop loss hit.
It's obvious.
Like I said, EMAs tells everything. This
was from the 24th. The stop loss.
I should have avoided this day easily.
Even I still make mistakes.
Also here, we are bullish. You can see
that the EMAs are pointing up. The price
is over them. This is the New York open.
We are looking for a bearish fair value
gap to be flipped. We have one right
here. Price will break it to the upside.
And yeah.
TP missed by a few ticks.
This was from the 25th.
The stop loss also.
This is the New York open we have here.
We are obviously bearish. We are looking
for a bullish fair value gap to be
flipped to the downside.
Here we have the entry, the stop loss as
conservative due to the couple of losses
I had the previous days.
Uh I targeted this liquidity right here
because I believe this day was the
reason of these two horrible days. Let's
play the price.
Our RR here was 3.3.
And TP
by the millimeter. Here we have the
26th, I made 6.5k.
This is an easy day, to be honest. These
two bad
New York open, we have a bullish FVG
right here. We are obviously bearish.
Entry here, stop loss right over
inversion candle  swing high.
Targeted two hours, I believe. Yes.
Took some time.
And TP, this was from the 27th
of March, a little bit on the
4k.
This video will be super long. Make sure
to leave all your questions in the
comment down below. Like and subscribe
and also follow me on Instagram.
Open right here. We have a very small
bullish fair value gap. We are obviously
still bearish because we are under the
one-hour EMA. I was targeting this
liquidity right here with big RR.
And TP hit. This was from the 30th of
March.
You can see here 8.82k.
Let's go to the last day of the month.
So, we have a New York open right here.
We opened above the one-hour EMA. My
bias is automatically switched to
bullish.
Now, I I to see a bearish fair value gap
and I need to see that price stays above
the 1-hour EMA.
We have a bearish fair value gap right
here. Price did go under the EMA for a
second, then returned.
Then we flipped this FVG, placed my stop
loss right at the EMA under the FVG,
under the inversion candle, previous
candle, everything, and it went for 2
hours.
TP that was from the 31st of March, so a
little bit over 4K. And again, if you
are super super driven, willing to put
the work, want to get numbers like this,
make sure to apply for my 101 mentorship
down below. And also to leave your
comments, your suggestions for next
videos. Like, subscribe, follow me on
Instagram. See you on the next one.